Next up, I'd like to talk about running Python at runtime. So we talked earlier of how Python
isn't a runtime language in the editor. It's mainly used within the editor.
Now that is true. However, there are some oddities about it. Now you can run it at
runtime, but only within the editor. So Python uses the editor utility library,
which is stripped out at the level of packaging. However, you can still use this within the editor.
I'm going to demonstrate that in a second. It might be worth knowing to you that the plugin
is actually a runtime plugin and therefore could theoretically be manipulated within C++ in order
to function. But that is experimental and more experimental than the standard stuff. So just
be wary. I wouldn't recommend it. One of the things that Python is used for is performance
testing or doing automation at runtime. And we have an automation lib which sits within the
unread. And this is an example of something that you can run whilst it is being played within
the editor. Again, at packaging this would all be stripped out. And this library though
is useful if you want to do anything like logging, comparing images, taking screenshots,
setting view modes, or changing the scalability options as you run. So we'll jump into the
editor and I'll demonstrate how you should do this because it's not straightforward.
So here I am back in the editor. I'm going to try and take a screenshot
based on the location you are within the editor. I have a Python script here which
is set to take a screenshot and it's going to take a timestamp and add that onto the screenshot
so that I can save multiple ones. So this is something which is a good example of something
that can be run at runtime. And again that's part of the automation library. I've saved
that as take-screenshot.py. And I'm going to open level blueprint. So here we go. Here is the
level blueprint. There's some code on it already but don't worry about that. I'm going to right
hand click and I'm going to create a node. And I'm looking for key Z. So that's a keyboard event
Z. Now this will be triggered when I push a button, but when I push the Z button to be
perfectly sure. Now if I want to run a Python script off of this, if I type in Python,
you're going to see that none of our normal Python nodes come up. And that's because the
Python nodes are only executable inside of actors which inherit from the editor utilities
base. So that can be an editor utility widget, an editor utility blueprint, or there are some
editor utility actors and so on. Anything you'd use to make a tool. However what we can do is
we can run a CVAL. So if I typed in execute, now you've got an option for execute console command.
Now we have the Python side here. However we can also, if we want to run a Python script,
type py and then the name of the Python script, which in this case is take-screen-shot.py.
If I press enter, you can see that we have our screenshot here. So that is the way that I can
run it from the command line. And in that case, if I jump in here, I would be able to place
that on an execute command within the screenshot. So if I go file save, now if I push play,
I will go full screen. To move around the editor, I'm going to take a close-up of
this widget. I press z. You can see that it's taken a screenshot.
Now I'll take one more of the chair over here, and again it's taken another screenshot.
Now if I come out of this and go back to my screenshot directory,
you can see that we now have those two screenshots that we've created.
And that brings us to the end of this short video on running Python at runtime.
I'll catch you in the next one.